hey what is up guys I'm cabby HD here
and these are my top five best
smartphones of 2013 now this is a
different way of doing this list this is
actually an unordered list it's not in
order and I just didn't really feel
right for me to pick a number one best
smartphone of the year but that being
said you can feel free to pick your
favorite and leave it in the comments
section below whether you do that before
or after watching this video but I'm
going to go ahead and look back at it
take a bit of a retrospective look at
five phones that really changed 2013
that were really important to 2013 and
that's why they made this list the first
for me is Moto X and Moto X changed 2013
because of its form factor and it's
quick updates so this is a phone that
didn't really originally appear to have
flagship specs when it first came out
obviously and I did my first review and
hands-on of it talking about that whole
deal and it's not a 1080p display and
it's not the highest end processor but
it feels amazing in the hand and it is a
great first time Android phone for
anyone considering switching to Android
from any other operating system and I
say quick updates because it was
literally almost before some other
nexuses to get KitKat it did beat the
Nexus 4 I believe to get the latest
version of Android 4.4 so if you care
about that latest pure Android
experience or even if you're an Android
is iasts like a real hardcore android
person you're still going to find a lot
to like in the Moto X so that was a
really interesting phone of the year I
turned a lot of heads next for me is the
Nokia Lumia 1020 now it may seem weird
to have another 720p phone on this list
and even more weird to have a Windows
Phone on this list but this phone
changed the way we look at cameras in
smartphones like for good permanently if
you saw the review of it I'll have all
the reviews on all the links to all
these phones that I talk about right
down below right below that like button
but the 1020 had a 41 megapixel camera
and I talked about that in great depth
in my full review of that phone and that
that's changed a lot we don't see 41
megapixel cameras at all really in the
wild these days whether it's in a DSLR
or a smartphone so the fact that they
were able to cram
at many pixels in that quality of glass
and sensor and all those optics into a
phone really change the way we think of
high-end smartphone cameras next up is
the HTC One which made the list for two
reasons its build quality and its
speakers this device changed what we
thought of smart phones for good in 2013
because of its build quality you never
really looked at the galaxy s4 the same
way after the HTC one came out that
phone was made of solid aluminum it was
a unibody precision milled and drilled
finish it was an overall amazing phone
to hold in the hand had that cold metal
feel when you wake up in the morning it
was a little bit weightier a little bit
more compact than the Galaxy s4 but
overall an amazingly well-built phone
and then it had those massive
front-facing boomsound speakers and
again that also changes the way you
think about audio in any other smart
phone when you consider someone who
wants the best sounding speakers in a
phone that's immediately the number one
recommendation have you looked at the
HTC One
it has boom sound speakers sounds
ridiculously good compared to anything
so those are the two reasons the one
made the list next up for me on my list
is the Galaxy Note 3 from Samsung and I
think this is the first real phone that
had pretty much no compromises all
across the board which is this is a true
high-end spec device in every single
department where the biggest actual
trade off is software whether or not you
like the TouchWiz skin on top of Android
but it had you know three gigabytes of
RAM had a 13 megapixel camera with
incredible photos and 4k video the only
weird thing about it was the whole black
versus white galaxy note 3 thing it's
not as weird as it sounds it was just it
was made of different materials the
black Galaxy Note 3 I think actually had
a much nicer build quality than the
white Galaxy Note 3 because the white
one would have stained if it was made of
the material that the black one was made
of but overall I'm a fan of that phone
and it was actually a little bit more
compact and had a little bit larger
battery and better battery life than the
Galaxy Note 2 so it was really an
improvement in every area one of my
favorite films of the year and still one
on a stick and keep around and last on
my list is number five which is the
Nexus 5 and this is a lot of you've been
asking what is my daily driver what
phone do you seem to carry around most
often this is it the
is essentially the closest thing I've
had to my daily driver for the past a
month or so I've carried the
Stormtrooper 32gig white nexus 5 and
it's on my list for not just KitKat
because it is the latest version of
Android as quickly as possible and a
nexus but for the price it has one of
the best price to spec ratios in any
smartphone to date it had the snapdragon
800 2 gigabytes of ram a 5-inch 1080p
display and the latest version of
android this is a top-notch phone that
Google is selling for $350 starting in
the Google Play Store so if you're able
to get your hands on it that's the tough
part if you're able to get your hands on
the Nexus 5 it is an amazing deal as
well as a great smartphone experience so
that is why the Nexus 5 made the list
believe it or not that's five already
that is my five best phones for 2013 now
there are plenty more smart phones of
course that I didn't mention wasn't able
to when talking about the best of you
can't not talk about the Samsung Galaxy
s4 when talking about 2013 that phone
was the best-selling smartphone and
really further established Samsung's
dominance in Android so the Galaxy s4
was their flagship for the year and was
a very good seller there was also the
Nokia Lumia 1520 which I reviewed pretty
recently actually one of my favorites
and the highest end I think best built
and best internally Windows Phone to
come out this year there's a blackberry
z30 sort of the blackberry flagship for
the year maybe not one of the best
phones of the year but certainly their
best and many many more the Moto G is
also something you should you should
talk about when you talk about 2013
because that price to performance ratio
under $200 to get the kind of specs and
performance in a phone like the Moto G
very impressive stuff now before I close
out I want to refer you guys to another
top 5 video from TLD today that's
actually going up today as well I'll
have a link right below that like button
to his best 5 phones of the year so you
get a different sort of perspective a
different look at it from another angle
we're both tech people but we both have
different tastes so his list is
different from mine so check that out
right below and I will be having more
sort of fun retrospective looks back at
this past year in tech coming up very
soon so be sure to subscribe if you have
already those are coming up very soon
that's all I have to say what is your
number one what's your favorite phone of
the past 365 days thanks for watching
I'll talk to you guys in the next video